d'où viennent les nuages c'est
typiquement le genre de questions que
les enfants posent et auquel on sait pas
toujours très bien répondre vous savez
vous ce qu'est vraiment un nuage et
comment il se forme alors si vous n'êtes
pas certains la réponse rassurez vous
vous n'êtes pas les seuls
en fait même les scientifiques n'ont pas
encore tout compris à la formation des
nuages et pire on va voir que en théorie
les nuages ne devrait même pas exister
[Musique]
les nuages joue un rôle essentiel pour
notre planète d'abord évidemment y
participent le cycle de l'eau puisqu'ils
sont à l'origine des précipitations est
donc deux départs le fait qu'on puisse
avoir des inondations ou des sécheresses
dans une zone où il entre mais les
nuages ont également une influence forte
sur les équilibres climatiques
c'est lié au fait qu'il réfléchisse une
partie de la lumière du soleil et
diminue donc la quantité d'énergie que
la terre reçoit les nuages couvrent en
moyenne les deux tiers de la surface de
la planète
et si on n'avait pas eh bien ils
feraient beaucoup plus chaud les nuages
sont d'ailleurs un des facteurs
d'incertitude les plus importants dans
les modèles climatiques actuels
c'est pourquoi mieux comprendre leur
formation est absolument essentiel pour
correctement reconstruire les climats
passés et simuler l'effet du
réchauffement climatique
bon donc c'est quoi un nuage eh bien on
va commencer par l'explication
traditionnelle au niveau des océans de
l'eau s'évapore
ça se produit aussi dans une moindre
mesure au dessus des continents et
notamment des forêts cette évaporation
c'est de la transformation d'os liquide
en vapeur d'eau vapeur qui ensuite par
dans l'atmosphère en tant que gaz la
vapeur d'eau est plus légère que le jazz
hot ou le dioxygène qui composent l'air
donc à la tendance à monter et sauf
qu'en altitude il fait de plus en plus
froid on perd environ 1 degré tous les
150 m et en se refroidissant la vapeur
d'eau fini par se condenser c'est-à-dire
qu'elle redevient de l'eau liquide
attention ça veut pas dire tout de suite
qui pleut un lot forme des gouttelettes
qui sont d'abord minuscule et ils
restent en suspension dans l'air tant
qu'elles ne sont pas trop grosse c'est à
dire à peu près en dessous d'un
millimètre
mais ces fines gouttelettes deviennent
visibles parce qu'elles diffusent la
lumière c'est à dire qu'un rayon
lumineux qui les frappe se trouve
renvoyée dans toutes les directions et
c'est pour ça qu'on voit des nuages dans
le ciel
ce qui est important dans cette
explication c'est le fait que la vapeur
d'eau au départ elle est invisible elle
ne se voit pas et c'est seulement après
condensation en petites gouttelettes
d'eau liquide qu'on voit quelque chose
pour les pros de l'apéro le phénomène
ressemble un peu à celui qui explique la
couleur du pastis et je vous renvoie à
ma vidéo sur le sujet cette histoire de
vapeur d'eau qui se condense c'est aussi
ce qui se produit juste au dessus d'une
casserole ou d'une bouilloire ça cette
espèce de fumée blanche
eh bien ça n'est pas de la vapeur d'eau
ou la vapeur d'eau c'est invisible ce
qu'on voit ici c'est vraiment de l'eau
liquide dans la bouilloire l'aube ou à
100° elle se transforme donc en vapeur
puis au contact de l'air qui est à
environ 20 degrés la vapeur se refroidit
et redevient liquide elle se condense en
formant des minutes
le gouttelettes et ce sont ces
gouttelettes convoi parce qu'elles
diffusent la lumière tel que je le dis
on a envie de penser que les nuages et
ce qu'on voit s'échapper de la
bouilloire c'est la même chose mais il
ya un truc qui cloche dans cette
explication c'est pas la même chose
l'eau des océans el bour pas aller
jamais à 100 degrés est en fait plus
généralement pourquoi est-ce qu'on a de
la vapeur d'eau dans l'air les rangs
bien il est à moins de 100 degrés donc
normalement à cette température-là l'eau
est liquide il devrait pas y avoir de
vapeur est bien pour éclaircir ça on va
reprendre un peu les choses à la base et
essayer de comprendre au départ pourquoi
l'eau s'évapore c'est un truc qu'on a
tous appris il existe principalement
trois états de la matière solide liquide
et gaz et le cas de l'eau est bien
connue elle devient solide en dessous de
zéro degré c'est la glace et gazeuse au
dessus de 100 degrés c'est la vapeur
d'eau ok mais en même temps on sait
qu'il ya la vapeur d'eau dans l'air et
puis on voit bien les flaques sèche
disparaissent même s'il fait pas cent
degrés l'eau des flaques ne bout pas et
pourtant elle s'évapore quand même alors
je me souviens qu'au lycée on nous
répétait de bien faire la différence
entre les bulles ition et l'évaporation
mais sans vraiment nous expliquer
pourquoi ce n'était pas le même
phénomène et pourquoi ça se produisait à
des températures si différentes
alors si comme moi vous n'avez jamais
vraiment bien compris cette histoire je
vais essayer de vous l'expliquer et on
va voir que ébullition et évaporation
c'est en fait fondamentalement le même
phénomène
[Musique]
la clé pour comprendre cette histoire
d'évaporation c'est que pour connaître
l'état solides liquides ou gazeux d'une
matière n'y a pas quatre température qui
compte
il ya aussi la pression voici ce qu'on
appelle un diagramme de phase
c'est le diagramme de phase de l'eau
vous avez la température en abscisses et
la pression en ordonnée attention
l'échelle est un peu spécial et le
diagramme vous indique l'état de l'eau
en fonction de ces deux critères par
exemple dans les conditions ambiantes il
fait mettons 20 degrés et un bar de
pression on elle l'art dans le diagramme
donc l'eau est liquide
si vous refroidit c'est en dessous de
zéro degré tout en restant à un bar et
bien l'eau devient solide et forme de la
glace est au dessus de 100 degrés
toujours à un bar de pression on passe
en forme gazeuse la vapeur mais si on
change de pression par exemple qu'on se
place à deux barres et bien l'eau
restera liquide jusqu'à 120 degrés et
c'est le principe de la cocotte minute
bon je pense que vous voyez à peu près
comme en utilisent ce genre de
diagrammes c'est pas très compliqué et
pourtant il ya un truc très important
qu'on nous explique pas toujours très
bien à son sujet on a dit il ya deux
choses qui comptent
la température et la pression alors la
température c'est la température ya pas
trop d'ambiguïtés mais concernant la
pression il est important de bien
comprendre qui met la pression
prenez un récipient contenant de l'eau
par exemple une bassine à une
température de 20 degrés
la pression de l'air au dessus et de 1
bar la pression ambiante mélo aussi
possède une pression est en fait si on
se met juste en dessous de la surface
c'est la même c'est un bar il ya un
équilibre les pressions sont identiques
de chaque côté maintenant mettons nous à
la place d'un petit volume d'eau dans la
bassine ce volume d'eau et à une
température de 20 degrés donc et il
subit une pression de 1 bar et il lui
mais cette pression et bien c'est l'eau
qui l'entourent il est soumis à un bar
de pression d'eau une pression qui est
causée par l'eau environnante dans le
diagramme un bar 20 degrés on a vu que
ce petit volume d'eau est censé être à
l'état liquide
et c'est le cas donc tout va bien
maintenant mettons nous à la place de
l'eau qui se trouve en surface
elle subit aussi une pression de un bar
mais qui lui est mise par qui est bien
par l'air au dessus
or l'herbe à ça n'est pas de l'eau et
donc c'est de la pression qui ne compte
pas pour se positionner dans le
diagramme c'est ça la clé du
raisonnement dans le diagramme de phase
de l'eau ce qu'on considère sur l'axé
vertical quand on parle de pression
uniquement la pression de l'eau et donc
pour l'eau qui est en surface bail en a
pas c'est zéro barre si vous voulez donc
dans le diagramme on est quelque part
par là dans une zone blu est censé être
gazeuses et c'est pour ça qu'à la
surface l'eau liquide se transforme en
vapeur excellent apport vous voyez que
ça n'a rien de mystérieux ou
fondamentalement différent de
l'ébullition
on utilise le même diagramme mais c'est
la pression de l'eau qui compte
et cette pression d'eau elle est
différente dans les deux situations les
molécules d'eau qui sont au milieu de la
bassine
elle voit une pression d'eau de 1 bar
mais pour celles qui sont en surface la
pression d'eau c'est zéro alors fait
zéro c'est pas tout à fait vrai vu que
les molécules d'eau s'évapore pour aller
dans l'air et bien l'air devient humide
c'est à dire qu'il n'est plus seulement
composée de diazote et de dioxygène mais
aussi de vapeur d'eau et ses molécules
bouge dans tous les sens et donc elle
exerce une certaine pression sur leurs
copines qui sont restés à la surface de
la bassine et pour savoir quelle
pression elle exerce pas c'est facile on
fait juste une règle de trois si l'air
et à une pression totale de 1 bar et
qu'il est composé à environ 79% di a zot
et 21% de dioxygène et qu'on imagine
qu'ils contiennent disons 0.5 pour cent
de vapeur d'eau est bien la pression
exercée par la vapeur d'eau sera 0,005
barre 5 millibars voyons le diagramme ce
que cette pression de 5me libardo
implique pour les molécules de la
surface sachant qu'on est toujours à 20
degrés eh ben on voit que malgré cette
légère pression d'eau les molécules qui
sont à la surface sont encore censés
passer dans l'état gazeux donc
s'évaporer et donc à 20 degrés si l'air
est composé de 0.5 pour cent de vapeur
d'eau est bien le processus
d'évaporation va quand même continuer
l'air peut encore se charger en vapeur
d'eau et on voit sur le diagramme que ça
peut durer jusqu'à ce que la pression
d'apport d'eau soit d'environ 23
milliards
et là on arrive à la frontière avec
l'état liquide et donc l'évaporation
cesse et donc quand on en arrive là
l'air ne peut plus accueillir de vapeur
d'eau on dit qu'il est saturé c'est ce
qu'on appelle 100 % d'humidité attention
100 % d'humidité ça veut pas dire que
l'air est composé à 100% de vapeur d'eau
ça veut dire qu'il est au maximum de ce
qui peut accueillir et ce qui est
important avoir en tête c'est que cette
quantité de vapeur qui fait qu'on
atteint 100 % d'humidité et bien elle
dépend de la température
on a dit qu à 20° c'était 23 milliards
de pression mais vous voyez sur le
diagramme qu'à une température de 10 ont
35 degrés
eh bien il aurait fallu aller à 56
millibars pour être sur la frontière
donc 23 min bars de pression de vapeur
d'eau c'est 100 % d'humidité quand il
fait 20 degrés mais c'est seulement
environ 41% du maximum quand il fait 35
degrés et c'est pour ça qu'on appelle ça
l'humidité relative
c'est en pourcentage du maximum de ce
qu'elle pourrait être et qui dépend de
la température à un petit mot quand même
pour vous expliquer ce qui se passe au
niveau microscopique on a dit que quand
on atteint 100 % d'humidité relative
l'évaporation cesse on a un peu
l'impression qu'à la surface de la
bassine les molécules se passent le mot
du genre ah ça y est c'est fait sans
qu'on s'en d'humidité on arrête de
s'évaporer alors non c'est pas comme ça
que ça se passe
en permanence des molécules d'eau
s'échappe de la surface s'évapore et
plus la température est élevée plus
c'est le cas et al'inverse en permanence
des molécules d'eau de l'air viennent se
condenser à la surface et ce d'autant
plus que l'air est humide et quand
l'humidité de l'air atteint 100% c'est
le seuil où les deux flux ce qu'on pense
donc même à 100 % d'humidité
il ya toujours des molécules qui
s'évapore mais en fait autant qui se
condense et donc la quantité d'eau dans
la bassine reste constante bien en
conclusion vous voyez que évaporation et
ébullition c'est vraiment le même combat
c'est juste la pression de l'eau qui
diffère pour les molécules qui sont
situés en surface
eh bien c'est la pression de vapeur
d'eau qui compte et pour celles qui sont
au milieu de la bassine c'est la
pression de l'eau qui en fait est égale
à la pression totale de l'air et quand
on chauffe l'eau de la bassine au delà
de 100 degrés et bien même un bar de
pression d'eau n'est plus suffisant pour
garder les molécules à l'état liquide
elle passe à l'état gazeux et donc ça
fait des bulles de vapeur au sein du
liquide et c'est pour ça que
l'ébullition a lieu au coeur du liquide
alors que l'évaporation seulement en
surface bien maintenant qu'on a clarifié
cette histoire d'évaporation revenons
aux mécanismes de formation des nuages
[Musique]
on l'a dit sur terre en permanence de
l'eau s'évapore principalement au niveau
des océans cette évaporation elle peut
se produire parce que l'humidité
relative au niveau de la surface est
inférieure à 100 % l'air est rarement
complètement saturé cette terre chargée
en vapeur d'eau s'élève et finit par
être refroidis dans les couches
supérieures de l'atmosphère dans le
diagramme de phase de l'eau ça
correspond à un mouvement de ce genre
par exemple la pression de vapeur d'eau
restent identiques mais la température
diminue ce qui fait une augmentation de
l'humidité relative jusqu'au point où la
vapeur devrait en principe revenir de
l'eau liquide
alors je dis bien en principe parce
qu'il ya une subtilité le passage de
l'état gazeux à l'état liquide la
condensation ne se fait pas de manière
si simple 100 % d'humidité c'est en fait
le seuil théorique à dépasser pour que
la vapeur d'eau commencent à se
condenser mais sur une surface plane
quand une gouttelette se forment et ben
ça n'est pas une surface plane c'est une
surface courbet et même très courbé un
vu que les gouttelettes au départ sont
minuscules
or pour ce conte dansé sur une surface
courbet 100 % d'humidité ça ne suffit
pas il faut que la pression de vapeur
d'eau soit supérieure à celle
correspondant à 100 % d'humidité
intuitivement la raison c'est que les
molécules s'échappe plus facilement
d'une surface courbe que d'une surface
plane et ce d'autant plus que la
courbure est forte et donc il faut un
peu plus de vapeur pour compenser on
appelle ça l'effet kelvin la courbe que
vous voyez ici représente l'humidité
relative qu'il faut pour que la vapeur
d'eau se condense en une goutte en
fonction de son diamètre plus la goutte
est petite plus l'humidité relative doit
être importante
sauf que les gouttes elle n'est ce pas
gros seins elles doivent commencer par
être petit avant de grossir par exemple
on lit sur le diagramme que pour que des
molécules d'eau sous forme de vapeur
puis se regrouper et former une
gouttelette de dison de nanomètres eh
bien il faut que l'air soit à 170 %
d'humidité
quand l'air contient plus de vapeur
d'eau que le seuil correspondant à 100 %
d'humidité
on dit qu'il est sursaturé et ça se
produit par exemple très bien au dessus
de votre boule noire ce qui sort de la
bouilloire c'est de la vapeur à 100
degrés et un bar de pression
et quand elle est refroidie brutalement
à 20 degrés et bien on a un bar de
vapeur d'eau alors que 100 % d'humidité
c'est pour 23 millibars on l'a dit donc
on est à 4300 % d'humidité relative on
est traître est sursaturé mais dans
l'atmosphère des telle saturation se
produisent pour ainsi dire jamais par
exemple ici vous avez des mesures
d'humidité relative
tu es à différentes hauteurs en plein
milieu d'un nuage et bat on n'arrive
même pas à 101%
donc on est très loin des conditions qui
permettent à un nuage de pouvoir se
former spontanément et du coup la
conclusion est sans appel
en théorie les nuages ne devrait pas
pouvoir se former sur la terre sauf que
les nuages bas on envoie donc il existe
qu'ils arrivent à se former même s'ils
n'y a que des toutes petites
sursaturation dans l'atmosphère alors
comment ça fonctionne
et bien la solution du mystère était
proposée par le métérologue suédois
hilding que leur colère le premier a
compris que les minuscules gouttelettes
d'eau qui constituent les nuages ne se
forme pas à partir de rien mais grâce à
l'aide de petites particules qui vont
faciliter l'initiation la condensation
on les appelle des noyaux de
condensation imaginez une petites
particules sphériques de mettons 100
nanomètres
si de l'eau se condense à sa surface la
courbure sera évidemment moins
importante que si la même quantité d'eau
c'était condensé sur elle même et donc
l'effet kelvin sera moins fort si on
reprend la courbe qui donne la
sursaturation nécessaires en fonction de
la courbure et bien on voit qu'avec des
noyaux de condensation de 100 nanomètres
ça commence à devenir possible avec des
sursaturation de seulement 100 1 % dans
tout ça est très bien sur le papier mais
d'où ils sortiraient ces noyaux de
condensation et bien il faut savoir que
l'atmosphère est pleine de minuscules
particules qu'on appelle des aérosols
il y en a en moyenne dix mille par
centimètre cube alors dix mille c'est
vraiment une moyenne de situations très
différentes puisque savane au moins d'un
millier dans les environnements naturels
à plusieurs dizaines de milliers dans
des environnements urbains pollués du
point de vue de leurs compositions ces
particules peuvent être de tout un tas
de nature 1 et ça dépend beaucoup de
l'environnement des poussières minérales
des cristaux de sel de mer des suies
mais aussi des gouttelettes d'acide
sulfurique ou de sulfate d'ammonium ou
encore des composés organiques et ce
sont toutes ces particules qui
permettent d'initier la condensation de
la vapeur d'eau en liquide et donc de
former des nuages
d'ailleurs cette activation du
changement d'état ressemble un peu à ce
qui se passe pour la formation des
bulles de champagne vous pouvez aller
voir ma vidéo sur le sujet ouais
champagne pastis à moi j'aime bien faire
la physico-chimie à l'apéro en
conclusion sans ces particules plus ou
moins naturel qui servent de noyaux de
condensation les nuages ne pourrait pas
se former ce qui compte avec ces
particules on l'a vu c'est
principalement leur taille mais il ya
aussi un effet de leur composition
chimique
on appelle ça l'effet raout sida vapeur
condense sous forme liquide sur un noyau
de condensation
et bien je peux commencer à le dissoudre
en partie et donc la gouttelette se
trouvera être un mélange d'eau et de
molécules provenant de la particule et
ça va réduire le phénomène d'évaporation
en surface puisque en quelque sorte ces
molécules qui ne sont pas de l'eau vont
bloquer une partie de la surface pour
l'évaporation est donc en plus de
l'effet de taille la nature chimique des
aérosols va faciliter la condensation de
la vapeur d'eau et donc la formation des
nuages mais il existe encore un dernier
phénomène favorable lui aussi d'origine
chimique
le fait que dans certaines particules on
retrouve des substances qu on appelle
des tensioactifs les tensioactifs ce
sont des molécules comme par exemple des
molécules de savon qui viennent se
placer à la surface de l'eau et qui
réduisent la difficulté de créer des
surfaces très courbé et de même que le
savon permet plus facilement de faire
des bulles et bien les tensioactifs vont
réduire l'effet kelvin et ce qui est
amusant dans cette affaire c'est que la
plupart des substances tensioactifs qui
facilitent la formation des nuages sont
vraisemblablement d'origine biologique
c'est à dire que la présence de la vie
et pas seulement les activités humaines
joue un rôle dans la formation des
nuages
ça peut paraître étonnant que la
présence du vivant puisse faciliter
l'existence des nuages on aurait pu
croire que c'était un phénomène purement
physique et pourtant il existe un cas
qui ressemble beaucoup qui est très
intéressant ce sont les canons à neige
dans cet épisode uniquement parlé de la
formation des nuages formés de
gouttelettes liquide les nuages show en
quelque sorte
mais il existe aussi des nuages de glace
comme les cyrus on retrouve à plus haute
altitude et le principe du canon à neige
c'est justement de créer un nuage de
glace à partir d'eau et d'air sous
pression et ce en quelques instants
et dans certaines situations pour
faciliter la transformation de l'eau en
glace
on utilise une bactérie cette bactérie
s'appelle pseudomonas irène g et elle
possède une propriété assez étonnante
celle de pouvoir faciliter la
congélation de l'eau même à des
températures très proche de zéro degré
et donc on utilise dans certains canons
à neige pour pouvoir faciliter la
production d'une belle poudreuse blanche
vous y penserez cet hiver si vous avez
dévaler les pistes
merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo si elle
vous a plu n'hésitez pas à partager
pouces bleus la cloche roussat vous
pouvez retrouver les actus la chaîne sur
facebook et sur twitter et ceux qui
souhaitent le veut soutenir sur typique
merci à bientôt
[Musique]